hey where fancy was this hat because
Abba Kadabra oh Abra Kadabra we always
are fancy we're always fancy girls Khloe
Kardashian and daughter true want you to
know their fancy girls we all want to be
cute over here okay Coco and her
four-year-old daughter share a peek into
their early morning on Instagram
freestyling about being fancy girls
we're always fancy girls but yeah
oh yeah sorry
and we all said the girls all the time
we know how to do it all this time and
we love to get dressed we love our hats
we love our glasses I just woke up so my
hair is all messy but with the hat no
one can tell the good American
co-founder posted not one but two clips
for our viewing pleasure Wednesday we
had fun we are the fancy girls yeah yeah
sure sure yeah yeah sure we're not the
50 Girls We Are
everybody says but not the Santa girl
now everybody says we are the fancy
clothes no sometimes oh just sometimes
sorry I just woke up so I'm not super
fancy sometimes but not fancy sometimes
where are fancy and if that has you
wanting more cocoa and true Chloe writes
that you can find more 6 a.m fancy talks
on Tick Tock my favorite part about
being a mom I mean it's so corny but
it's just like no matter how tired you
are whatever you just it's complete
Bliss
Chloe wasn't the only Kardashian
bringing the cute kid content isn't that
crazy on Tuesday night Kim shared a
series of selfies snuggled up in bed
with her son Saint in one pick she
writes is there really anything better
in this life and in another she gushes
over his sweet face I don't know how
you're gonna top that but all that kiddo
Bliss came to a screeching halt quote
forget it he just punched me in the eye
in his sleep and rolled over not as cute
as I thought having kids is just there's
no way to describe it but it's a lot
might be a lot but it sure keeps fans
entertained it's really fun to see
specifically Saints big sis North who's
a social media Pro serving up some grade
A content like the time she pranked her
famous mom pretending to shave off her
eyebrow with a Tick-Tock filter
wake up Mia I'm awake I'm really
freaking out or how about that time she
used special effects makeup to transform
into her dad Kanye West
[Music]
and most recently she teamed up with
Mariah Carey's daughter Monroe for this
epic moment
so whether it's northie on Tick Tock or
true on Instagram we're here for all the
Kardashian kiddo moments bye bye
[Music]